in the not-too-distant future scientists
may be able to simply scan a star for
earth-like planets and find the
signature of life there we can look
right at the light from a little planet
around its distant star and that opens
up a whole range of possibilities for us
to not just detect the planet but to
study the planet I mean this all sounds
like science fiction but there is a
reality to this we have a scientific
method to actually determine whether
there is life on another planet life is
one thing intelligent life another all
together that requires billions of years
and a powerful force field like the one
we owe our lives to every day
if an alien astronomer were to file a
report on our home solar system they
might make a surprising observation
because of all the eight planets that
orbit the Sun they could easily conclude
that two not one
were suitable for life
it's an easy mistake to make because the
Sun has two planets within its
Goldilocks zone
the Earth and Mars
both planets have surfaces warm enough
for liquid water to pool on but while
the earth is blessed with warm liquid
oceans Mars is dry and dead the one
crucial difference between these two
planets could be the key to finding
truly habitable exoplanets a magnetic
shield our Sun is constantly hurling
deadly radiation out towards us only our
magnetic shield the magnetosphere saves
us without it the solar wind would blow
our atmosphere away and without an
atmosphere liquid water could not exist
on the surface in order to have liquid
water not only do you need the right
temperature but you need the right
pressure you know if there were no
atmosphere here right now even at the
same temperature we are today
all of the water would boil off into
vapor immediately so where does the
Earth's magnetosphere come from and why
does it Mars have one actually in the
past both Earth and Mars had
magnetospheres but Mars lost its around
4 billion years ago and with it the
potential for life
both the earth and Mars were born into a
realm of violence asteroids smashed into
their surfaces turning rock and metal
into a molten mass as they started to
cool a solid crust formed on the surface
but the molten metal below churned as
the planets turn inducing a magnetic
field which rose high up above the
surface of both planets at the same time
active volcanoes pumped gas into the
space around each planet protected by
the newly formed magnetic field these
gases built up into thick atmospheres
creating the air pressure for liquid
water to run on the surface for over a
hundred million years both Mars and
Earth for warm wet paradises primed for
life to take off then quite suddenly
Mars's magnetic protection disappeared
the solar wind blew its atmosphere into
space and its oceans boiled away leaving
the dry sterile red rock we see today